hi
this is dr gregory sadler i'm a
professor of philosophy
and the president and founder of an
educational consulting company called
reason i o
where we put philosophy into practice
i've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years
and i find that many people run into
difficulties reading classic
philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured
but the concepts themselves are not
always that complicated and that's where
i come in
to help students and lifelong learners
i've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube
many viewers say they find them useful
what you're currently watching is part
of a new series of shorter videos
each of them focused on one core concept
from an important philosophical text
i hope you find it useful as well
let's look now at another interesting
set of virtues we're not going to get to
the anger one
unfortunately but i i have resources if
you're really interested in that because
i
don't want to work on that
okay
let's think about this ambition
when we say somebody is ambitious
what is that drive there someone calls
it philotymia
which means love of honor
is that all that we mean when we say
somebody is ambitious that they just
desire
honor what do we think
yeah we're looking for success
we're looking for status
sometimes we substitute respect for the
word honor i think that is
you know unless you're a very
traditional person you don't often talk
about honor you probably talk more about
respect or scheme
or a few other things now
what's really interesting about this
particular set of virtues and vices
aristotle actually says in his culture
there is no term for the for the mean
that people talk about
some people being
too ambitious and other people not being
ambitious enough
and the greek society that he lived in
was a real go-getter society
these people were very interested in
status and prestige
and you know advancing in power and that
sort of stuff
and comparing themselves to other people
i guess you know this would also be
about
you know comparing yourself to other
people not just in terms of like job
position or things like that but also
like what you have
you know who you know all those sorts of
things reputation
and he says that the two extremes in
some sense can
vie for the center that
a lot of people will will call somebody
ambitious and sometimes they mean it is
a bad thing sometimes they mean it is a
good thing sometimes they call the
middle
part being ambitious and sometimes they
call
the middle part being unambitious
you know do you think this is the case
still for us today that we don't really
have a good
way of talking about people who are
motivated
to the right extent when it comes to
these sorts of
desires and drives looking for status
reputation respect
how other people see them
do we have a trend that we use for
people who are just right
what is it that's a hustler a hustler
so they're just they're just right or
are they more on this
end uh the hustler they're thinking
about is one that like
puts in hopefully the time and effort
and so he gains what he wants and then
eventually
it just compounds indeed okay so they're
not like cutting corners
trying to you know people who want to
attain immediate celebrity would be over
here
i'm going to post a youtube video of me
doing something crazy
and then i'll have my own tv show there
are people who think that
right that's why there's a lot of crazy
youtube videos out there that you can
find
and they often are quite funny that's
very different than building something
up over time
yeah it's it's interesting
you let's let's actually let's use that
person who's genuinely a hustler
in this sense somebody who's building
a reputation you you have to build
reputation by actually doing something
that other people value
and it's got to be something sustainable
doesn't it so it's got to be part of who
you are
and if you really want
other people's approval or you know
respect
or things like that too much you won't
do that will you
you will cut corners you will sacrifice
other things to to that good
what about on this end are there people
in our society who are not ambitious
enough
who are not concerned enough about
how other people see them about
respect position those sorts of things
do you think so yeah
yeah some people may be this way just
because
they'd rather just like you know yeah
lay on the couch and watch tv all day
right
and some people may be this way they
they may be the dreamers the people who
say yeah i got this big plan
but nothing they never do the steps that
are
that are required in order to be
successful
right the the person who's here ought to
be successful
unless something comes along to really
screw things up
there could be other people who just see
themselves as unworthy of that
like with the pleasure one you know i'm
never going to amount to anything
so why should i why should i try just
let me
you know do what i what i do
could there other be could there be
other modes of this sort of
just going through the phases so going
to school not because you want to look
because
ah yeah the people who
do things that are actually good for
them which could be part of building
uh you know a repertoire of skills
contacts all those sorts of things
but they don't really their heart's not
in it and they have no idea why they're
doing it
i don't see that much here at marist
i've seen that at some other places
where i've taught
where the students have this idea that i
i just got to make it into college and
that things are going to like fall into
place
they have no idea what they're doing in
college they have no no idea why they
ought to be there and if you don't have
any idea why they have to be there
they can't have any idea about what to
get out of it
what to what to do what to you know
what steps to take to assure that
they're actually going to be successful
really you know what aristotle is
talking about here in terms of right
ambition
is a matter of assuring
that you are going to be successful
and
working to be successful
this person over here wants to be
successful
wants to be acknowledged by everybody
without necessarily putting in the work
the person over here might actually do a
lot of work
but they for one reason or another
are not going to um things aren't going
to fall in place you know there are some
people
actually too out there who kind of
trip themselves up you see them working
but they always manage to sort of uh
derail themselves whenever whenever it
comes to a really important
juncture whether they're going to do the
presentation where somebody might
actually see them
and then give them some what aristotle's
calling honor
have we seen people like that they might
be over here
they really are not motivated by my
ambition
enough what would be some other signs of
somebody
here in the middle do you think
in our culture
in arizona's culture you know be the
guys out there
trying to get political law office it's
easy to get political office back though
there are a lot of different positions
putting on big dinner parties sometimes
you know because that would be part of
how you would make contacts
what do we do if you want let's think
about it this way as a student
if you actually have right ambition
the right amount of
wanting to be you know wanting to have
approval from other people
wanting to be respected by other people
um
what would that look like for you guys
how would you approach your teachers
you guys want to be valued by us don't
you at least in terms of grades but i
think a lot of you
actually care about what we think at
least some of your professors
because the professors that you actually
think have a hit on the wall
maybe your your major professors
what sort of things would be
characteristic of your your attitude
towards them the way you make decisions
think about assignments go go ahead like
respectful
yeah i think that's that's part of it um
think about assignments
when you put in workout assignments are
you just trying to like put in all the
bells and whistles to impress somebody
are you trying to produce solid work
it's all at work and presses people at
least if those people have anything on
the ball i know some of your professors
may
you know be those guys nobody gets an a
you know
that's that's that's actually a problem
for marisland's perspective
too showing up on time yeah
that's important i think that goes in
with being respectful doesn't it
now what about um things that you do for
yourself
going to office hours so you can
understand stuff you probably know
yeah um professors are always surprised
when students shop in office hours
because so few students do
but people were usually pleasantly
surprised um
what else what are some things what are
some steps that you're taking for
yourself
here at marist besides how you interact
with professors
to assure that you're going to be
successful what are some things
okay so that goes into learning and
acquiring skills are there any other
things that you're
are there any ways you're trying to
excel to call attention to yourself
things that are going to go into your
your resume
when you go out on the job market
some of you are doing internships right
that's a smart move i'm glad that at
marist they're so good about you know
making students do that that this is
kind of a stretch at this point
isn't it but that actually could fit
into what aristotle is calling this
virtue of right ambition
do you shoot for the flashy internships
that
you know you may not actually be
qualified for
do you sell yourself too short and not
go for the internship that you probably
are qualified for if you guys are you
know pretty smart
students made it in here you've made it
this far
do you seek out opportunities that are
actually commensurate with your
your abilities and your talents and your
potential
that are going to be productive for you
and also make good contact for you
that would probably be here um
you could then think the same thing
about claws any of your participating
clubs
activities those sorts of things
they're not just resume builders right
if all you're doing is like stuffing
your resume
that's over here if you're really
doing things because that is part of who
you are
and you are able to contribute something
and
you do want other people to like see
that and say
yeah that that person is a good
contributor
you may be over here instead
maybe being a team player is kind of
like this
as well again some people just don't
care about that sort of thing and
aristotle thinks that's a deficit
what do you guys think do you agree with
aristotle
on this that there's sort of a mean
position or
do you think maybe it's better to be
like you know the person over here
what do you guys think that that'll be
our closing point
because over here to help you over like
two minutes extra
unfortunately
what's your what's your gut feeling
you don't want to be this right does
anybody in here want to be this
so which which should you be yeah well
the only problem on ambitiousness a lot
of times some people that choose inside
they may come out to just being lazy
they don't want to actually
apply yeah so yeah there is a mean
i don't know i wouldn't know
if you're unambitious it's not
necessarily a bad thing but it's almost
like what you mean
or you're intent by it yeah so if you
just don't want to apply yourself
that's a problem i don't know you guys
very well because you know it was
early in the semester uh i don't i i i
have a hard time picturing i didn't use
lazy
so i don't think any of you fit in here
or see yourself as fitting in here do
you see yourself as fitting in here
do you want to do you see this is a good
thing
yes all right well we'll leave off there